hello and welcome to videos meta 08
smell ponent oh another video ok seems
to be popular recently he actually plays
this yeah this is the thing I don't know
how it works if I was a critical move
but I have no idea oh wow not G 4 I
thought but ok I mean that doesn't look
bad okay I'm taking I really have to
know just play maybe this committee five
I don't know what's correct here
one looks vulnerable g5 winning a five
looks a little bit on the shaky side but
it's maybe possible it's possible
it's a big Center porn but I have a
pretty nice leading development so it
shouldn't be bad for what okay so Queen
age five now is a move definitely or
they are Queen h5 I'm kind of expecting
him to play 97 but you cannot go to f6
that easily so let's start with this
move the simple idea is just H for
that i did not have on the radar
hmm
let me put this actually
maybe I should have played f4 and step
that was was also quite a good option
instead of Queen age 5c five I did not
did not fully appreciate okay so let's
and that's that's very risky move I mean
you kind of expect him to take but you
never know so he calculated Queen f5 but
still let's do it takes takes takes and
threatening Bishop before at d and check
so if i go and now in the corner takes
it Bishop before this curtain so he has
to move the Queen Queen e5 looks like
then what why is that possible oh wow
wow wow wow EPA EPA I totally did not
see that shoot oh my god how unnecessary
was that mean I could have just played
look f2 wind I'm just better for nothing
ah
you great I hate those kind of gift
games yeah where the other side really
plays badly and then you give him like
Russia I got the point I mean that was
really rubbish share with whom it is
this g5 stuff and so on I don't think
it's good yeah should blunder full piece
threatening look edge for him okay oh
it's graydon find some cool moves to
defend at six now should hold for him
and fortunately
with this he has two player and he
manages yeah check is very easy enough
for him to to win but can still try
and one of those gift games jump even
that wins
don't even have a true can
time warning no matter if I ok doesn't
matter
check Queen Elsa group GA is a final
trick not is not a difficult one to the
spot but still rook h3 now is that
suitable irritating somewhat hook age 6
let's go droop d sexy
hey okay white bears I'm late I hate
those kind of games am I yeah this
position Kevin it came the engine things
it's kind of ok for like but it just
it's just not good yeah just not good
chance g5 c5 like weakening everything
and just kind of hope that the other guy
blunders piece so a form TX tix here
yeah and I mean this is just completely
sheltered it just just should just play
through gave two or whatever King edge
one actually does work in our playbook
you want first and this is actually not
bad because this position is definitely
nice for white because he has absolutely
no porn structure now NASA desolee
between age five was a blind spot I can
also play this and just play for them in
years called an extremely weak square
here another week square here so I can
go to the 5 and so on yeah the computer
will defend us I'm completely that's
completely clear but it's not nice in a
practical game the other thing is I also
instead of Queen age five ahead f4 that
was the other thing that I was
considering maybe this is really
stronger like takes Queen takes looks
extremely tricky for black it's got no
development a very weak King side this
is maybe stronger yeah Tim get this
check just you're taking and giving
giving him this assembly something under
that and ok check the
unfortunately here just know it no real
tricks around everything still still
work them okay thanks for watching